a thorn and Hillary Clinton side Bernie
Sanders knows his rival is just 145
delegates away from locking up the
Democratic presidential nomination but
he is not discouraged now we fully
acknowledge we are good in arithmetic
that we have an uphill climb ahead of us
but we are used to fighting uphill
climbs after defeating Clinton in West
Virginia he argued he would do better
against Republican Donald Trump in a
general election and that is exactly
what his supporters want to hear I have
full confidence at Bernie will still win
denomination we will have a contested
convention and indienne Bernie's gonna
win the nomination and he's going to
become our next president our next
Democratic nominee I think that a lot of
other people who are Sanders supporters
are in the same position as me and we'd
like to see the Democratic Party go back
to what it was before before Bill
Clinton Sanders continues to do well
with young voters but Clinton's lead is
looking highly insurmountable Bernie
Sanders victory in West Virginia is
obviously cheering his supporters here
in Washington and yet it doesn't really
change anything fundamental about the
state of the race Hillary Clinton is
still far and away the favorite to
clinch the nomination and yet Sanders
supporters here Washington are telling
us they want him to keep the battle
going right the way to the convention
for many weeks to come the question is
is that going to make it harder for
Hillary Clinton to focus her fire on
Donald Trump